- Hi, good evening everyone.
Welcome to the first event
of the spring semester
for the Franke Program.
I'm Priya Natarajan.
I happen to be the current
Director of the Franke Program
in Science and the Humanities,
which as you all know,
is Yale's flagship
interdisciplinary program.
We have a very exciting roster
of events for this semester.
And today we have a very special event,
one that charts a personal
intellectual journey
across disciplines by Dr. Andrew Koh.
But first, I would like
to thank our benefactors,
Mr. and Mrs. Richard and Barbara Franke,
whose generosity enables both activities
at the Franke Program, today's event,
as well as many other
interdisciplinary activities at Yale.
And before I introduce Dr. Koh,
I'm required to give you this notice
that Yale University is photographing
and videotaping this event.
There's a possibility
that you may be included
in these visuals by being
present during these activities.
You consent to the use of
your appearance, likeness,
and voice by Yale for standard nonprofit,
educational news related promotional
and or editorial purposes.
And before I forget, as per usual,
after today's talk and the Q an A,
we will be gathering for a
dinner reception upstairs
in the student lounge
immediately after this event.
So on to today's event,
I am delighted that we
have today as our speaker,
Dr. Andrew Koh, who is an archeologist
and who is an ancient historian
with a strong interest in
pharmacology and medicine,
with a focus on ancient
innovation and technology,
and other discoveries and new knowledge
that was generated in antiquity
that we are able to study
today with modern techniques.
He is the museum scientist
for the Yale Peabody Museum,
and he's a faculty
member in the Department
of Near Eastern Languages
and Civilizations
and the Council on Archeological Studies.
He's a active field
archeologist who's the PI
of the Southern Focused
Regional Project in Greece,
and Yale's Ancient Pharmacology Program
at the Peabody Museum.
Before I turn over the floor to him,
I just wanted to mention a
couple of upcoming events.
Tomorrow, January 25th,
although it's not our event,
but it may be of interest to many of you,
is a panel discussion
called Beyond Human Meaning
a conversation with Professor
Gary Tomlinson on the subject
of his new book of the same title.
And on Tuesday, March
26th, we have a screening
of "Richland" a new
documentary on a small town
that's struggling with
its identity as a center
of weapons grade plutonium production.
And on April 4th we have a
talk by Christian Cooper,
the victim of the Central
Park bird watching incident,
who's an avid bird watcher,
and he'll be talking to us about that.
And we have a talk by
Professor Meredith Broussard
on big data and the race,
gender, and ability bias
that is embedded in big data.
And then we have a talk
by Professor Anjan Bhullar
on the main scientific consultants.
He was one of the main
scientific consultants
for the documentary series that many
of you might have seen,
"Life on Our Planet."
Anyway, back to today's event.
I am really delighted
to invite Dr. Andrew Koh
to come and talk to us.
Thank you so much, Andrew.
- Thank you.
(audience clapping)
Welcome everybody on
this sort of a rainy day.
Thanks to Director, Priya,
and I think Ty is somewhere in the back.
And the Franke family,
as I mentioned to them,
it makes me exceedingly happy
that this Franke Program exists,
because that's gonna be
kind of like the theme
of my time with you today
is kind of the journey
I've taken, a spoiler alert.
As somebody in a kind
sense that said to me,
I'm likely the squarest peg in academia
with a lot of round holes.
So I wanna kinda share that journey
and talk about what experiences I've had.
And also perhaps it might be helpful
for all the different and
interesting people here.
So I wanna start our
somewhat strange journey,
if I can call it that.
That was the alternate title, you know,
the Yale Ancient Pharmacology Program
Exploring Strange New Worlds.
And you'll see here in
a second, it's relevant.
It's my first time flying this.
I'll preface it by saying,
I did not expect this ever.
It was not on my bingo
card, or bucket list,
or anything like that, to
distribute some of my friends
who are in fact, die hard Trekkies.
What happened was, let's
say late '21, early '22,
very much in the midst of the pandemic,
I did an interview with a journalist.
You do these things, you don't
know exactly what it's for,
which sounds kind of naive in retrospect.
He was in front of a
fireplace holed up in a cabin,
and he said he was a writer.
And he said he does a
whole bunch of things,
and this could be relevant
to various things.
So I had very little idea
of what this was all about.
What I did know is he
asked me very particular
and astute questions, "What
model of instruments do you use
when you do your extractions?
What do you think the
past as the present is?"
So I did this interview
for almost two hours,
which was the longest I've
ever done one of these.
And I thought maybe it'll
appear in the magazine
as he intimated.
And I didn't hear back from him
until I was just back from
my field work in Greece,
let's say July.
He texts me and I later
found out it was him,
because I'd been with him on the phone,
but I never received the text.
So who knows what this text is all about?
Because all it said was,
"Check out the latest episode
of Star Trek."
(audience laughing)
Was all it said.
And in fact, I thought it
was some kind of spam email
from some kind of streaming
unit or something like that.
Later on, and again, this sounds strange,
somehow in August or September,
something jogged my memory
and said, "Wait, was that the
person who interviewed me?
Like, you know, many months ago?"
I checked and indeed
it was the individual.
So then I looked at the
timestamp and I said,
I didn't even have a subscription
to the streaming service.
So finally I said, you
know, "I'll try that."
And I looked, and to my surprise,
not only did they include some
kind of interpretation of it,
but in the opening segment,
as you'll see here,
it basically sums up my research,
at least as Dave interpreted it.
So after I present my, you know,
directly what I've done the
last, let's say 20 years,
I'll leave it up to you
to judge how good of a job
they did in terms of interpreting my work.
Again, this was not on my
any kind of bucket list.
And to my surprise, this happened.
Just to preface it, this is the prequel
to the original series.
And in the original series,
they threw out an occupation
or discipline of a researcher.
And it never plays a role significantly.
And this discipline that
they invented in the sixties,
in the original series, they
dubbed archeological medicine.
And apparently they then, in
more recent memories, said,
"Oh shoot, we we're doing this prequel
that leads up to the original series.
We actually got a nuance
what this actually means."
And now I think that's
why they went to me.
They somehow found me and said,
"You're the closest
thing to this, you know,
fictional future discipline."
And to my surprise, again,
this is apparently now "Star
Trek" canon to the chagrin
of my friends, who, when I showed it
to one of my Trekkie friends
up the hill, he was like,
"You don't even have a paid
subscription to Paramount.
This is offensive to me, right?"
So, I have a paid subscription now.
So, this is the clip for two minutes.
Of course it has my, here we go,
- [Christine] The log, startdate 1789.3.
We're on route to the Vulcan system.
Our mission to survey the moon of Kerkhov
on the far side of the sector.
An ancient civilization once
lived there, then vanished.
Long range scans suggest the presence
of a strange energy anomaly
just above the surface.
A few of us are hoping that
it will provide answers
about where the Kerkhovians went.
As for the rest of the crew,
the captain has decided to
travel at sub-impulse speeds,
so we can all take in the view.
Now we find ourselves with an excess
of the most valuable
commodity in the galaxy.
- I own one of those
- Downtime.
I'm using it to print for an interview
for a two month fellowship
sponsored by the Vulcan Science Academy.
- What are Korby's three principles
of archeological medicine?
- One, medicine is always ancient and new.
As cultures' understanding
of what medicine is
changes over time.
(fists thumping)
Two, the keys to solving our
toughest medical problems
are often found by looking backward.
- Correct.
- Three, as a result,
archeological medicine
is as much a study of
history as it is of science.
- Drink.
- All right, so that's
a, believe it or not,
it's literally the points I
gave them for the most part.
So, again, something very unexpected.
So now I'll actually
share with you my research
that actually references,
they distilled into
that two minute segment.
Like I said, by many measures, I can say,
happily, I really shouldn't exist
for reasons I'll detail in a second.
I happily am doing what I'm doing.
But there were many moments, you know,
when I was sitting there in
the nineties at Abbott Labs,
I didn't ever imagine,
I'll be sitting here
in front of you talking about archeology.
So that's the journey I've been on,
and it is amusing that
somehow the Star Trek universe
apparently wants me to exist.
You know, more than perhaps one
would automatically presume.
I wanna start by conveying
the simple premise,
simply enough, organics were
central to ancient societies,
but are now invisible.
That's something we often forget
when we think about archeology.
We have remnants that
are displayed proudly
on the cover of Archeology Magazine.
Gold trinkets, vessels,
beautiful funerary vases from,
you know, southern Italy.
What we don't know is for the ancients,
it was what was inside of them, typically,
these kind of vessels.
That was the most important thing.
So we are in fact missing
for the most part,
the entire reason for the
existence of these vessels.
We're getting the shells, right?
The echoes of what really
mattered often to these ancients.
And for the longest time we thought
that we couldn't really
access this information.
There was a general sense
that this was important,
but we can't get to it.
And perhaps as an
ambitious graduate student,
maybe in retrospect, it
was a exercise in hubris.
But nevertheless, I
thought, you know what?
I want to give this a shot.
I have a background.
My undergraduate degree was in biophysics
and also Classic and Ancient
Near Eastern studies.
So I went to bring that
together, which is not easy,
because I can graduate
school in Philadelphia.
I had these two streams, but
to kind of bring them together
as this audience would understand,
it wasn't the easiest thing to do.
So I wanna share some of
those experiences now.
So how did we approach, how
did I approach this conundrum
of having really no organic surviving?
So the approach as it's defined
today is archaeochemistry.
So what it is, is simply
just the discovery
of ancient organics and
determining their relevance today.
How are they different,
how are they similar?
So on and so forth, I'm
always connecting it
to the present and future, of course.
And also utilizing a
transdisciplinary method
to characterize these
ancient organic residues,
because these things are
elusive, they're ethereal, right?
And as you might know, as someone said,
the chemistry doesn't lie,
but we get these remnants of residues,
compounds, organic compounds,
and they can come from
different sources, right?
The interpretation is
where we're fallible.
And how we get to that, as you'll see,
is what I'm calling this
transdisciplinary method
where ancient texts, ancient iconography,
all these different other
clues kind of help us hone
what the chemistry is telling us.
And that's why it's important to do it
in a very interdisciplinary manner
as fits what exactly this Franke Program
is trying to support.
And finally, why, again,
why do we do these things?
We want to recover compelling evidence
of what we're calling
non-linear innovation,
technology, craft, et cetera.
Because we know about how
things kind of pass down to us.
You know, we can talk about Roman roads
and they're not that
different from modern roads,
but what particularly intrigues
me is are there instances
where they might have
stumbled upon something.
Something that, you know,
I say right off the bat,
I'm not trying to find the
cure for cancer, for instance.
I don't have those kind of, you know,
aspirations necessarily,
but what really intrigued me
is one of the compounds I found
was heavy doses of zometa acid,
some aldehyde and other things.
And when I did a search
for them, I found out
that they in fact identified
the plant that I was targeting.
A plant that only grows in today's, like,
let's say modern southwest Turkey
and all the articles were medical, saying,
"We're using these plants
to try to research medical
cancer treatments."
So I thought that was fascinating.
Like, what does this come to?
How does this come to bear
in terms of how we do
this kind of research?
So I don't think it's a forced,
it's difficult to present
to you that modern pharmacopea
is actually still alive
and kicking today in many ways, right?
Things aren't all from a test tube.
I was alerted to this because
this might be outdated now.
I'm not sure if Moroccan is still popular,
but my significant other uses this
and what I caught is that, like,
for instance, one of these
smaller vessels to the left,
it was like $80, right?
So I was like, "Oh my gosh, this is $80."
So I looked more into it
because the background
was very fascinating to me.
And it's very interesting that to show you
how international it is,
and it must have been
similar in antiquity.
It's a company, if I remember correctly,
it's a US company based in London
who sources the botanical
ingredients in Morocco,
but manufactures it in the
Southern Levant of Israel.
So again, showing you
what is involved, right?
A very complex situation.
There's still abundant value today,
but what can we retrieve
from antiquity, right?
That was the million dollar question.
So it started almost
exactly 20 years ago now,
believe it or not, that's when
I started my dissertation,
and I'm calling it the Beginnings At A
"Minoan Perfumed Oil Workshop."
It's a very technical term
amongst this very small group
of scholars that work on Crete.
If you guys know the
legends of King Minos,
so on and so forth.
These are the archeologists who specialize
in this very particular time
period of Bronze age Greece,
even though Sir Arthur Evans,
and many of you have probably
been to Crete and Knossos,
that's that culture and complex society.
So I worked on an American
site in East Crete that summer.
And I wasn't trying to do
archaeochemistry, in fact,
at the moment I was trying
to do everything but,
I was trying to be as best as possible,
a round peg and not a square peg.
And as we're digging
this site, we came upon
what was immediately labeled the vat room
because they found this vat
that you can see pointed
in C2, right, so, which was very neat.
And as we're excavating,
I noticed several things,
and this is where kind of like
your interdisciplinary eyes really helped.
I said, "This is an incredibly
clean room for archeology."
And that might not be
enough for archeologist
that's traditionally trained just to stop
and say, "Okay, whatever."
They'll probably overlook it.
But then I saw other clues,
there's like a work bench
with like cutting and pounding tools.
And the floors mean for
bronze age standards,
that's a very clean room.
The floor is very clean.
And the vat kind of looked
a little suspicious to me
because there were many
shirts inside of it.
But the director said to me,
"Andrew, you're wasting your time on this.
It's a wine vat."
In fact, we found some
wine vessels next door,
so why bother with this?
So building up some
goodwill, serving for him,
and so on and so forth, doing things
that he needed me to do, I asked him,
"It's not gonna cut into
that time, but after hours,
can I collect samples and just for kicks,
take them back to Philadelphia
and then analyze them."
He said, "Sure, as long
as it's on your time."
So on and so forth.
So I never imagined a
dissertation would come out of it.
I thought it would just
be interesting to do.
So I took the samples and
from the get go, he said,
'It's just gonna show that it's wine,
which is, okay, interesting,
but nothing to dwell upon."
So what I did was I really
tried hard to look for wine,
but again, this is probably,
that's not obviously good science.
You should let the data speak to you.
That was my first lesson
right off the bat.
And what I found out was
that there was zero evidence
for wine, no tartaric acid,
no citric acid, you know,
malvidin, so on and so forth.
Instead, I found all
these other ingredients,
including trace amounts
of what we would call
aromatics roughly.
And then what became clear is
that it's what has been known
in this field of Minoan
archeology for over a century,
what's called a perfumed oil workshop.
This was a term invented
in the very early days
of archeology there, in the
days of Sir Arthur Evans
and Carl Blegen, these
pioneers of Minoan archeology.
So again, this is a early
lesson in that you need evidence
and insight from many
different perspectives,
because you had the chemical ingredients.
But then we had standing on the shoulder
of these giants who basically discovered
the earliest written
examples of Greek, right?
Called Linear B,
there's these famous
perfumed oil tablets, right?
And that's when this seemed
to coincide with that.
They've never found a
so-called perfume oil workshop.
We know it exists because in
addition to it being written
in these tablets, there are depictions of,
as the wonderful beautiful flyer put out
by the Franke Program.
You might have seen the saffron collector.
So there's examples of
people picking ingredients
and even, especially in
Egypt, slightly different,
but they're making these
kind of perfumed oils.
So we know about this tradition
from this exact same time period.
And then I could connect
the dots, extrapolate,
and then be able to nail down
where these chemical compounds come from.
That's the most difficult thing,
because there's many options.
You gotta know the local
flora, you gotta know,
like the chemistry has to make sense,
the botany has to make
sense, so on and so forth.
So the tablets gave me clues
what ingredients there might be.
Like coriander is used
as an astringent, right?
Because olive oil doesn't
naturally receive scent.
So I was able to reconstruct
basically how this might all work.
There's all these other clues, right?
One of the plants is this creticus,
is mentioned by the father of
ancient history, Herodotus.
It mentions, you know, in
an ethnographic fashion
what it's all about.
And then related to the flyer
photo, right near there,
there's this depiction that
people always kind of thought
it might be Cretan Rockrose,
it might be another plant.
But again, it's a two-way street.
By me discovering this,
then the people doing more
art historical endeavors
are saying we are more confident
that it's in fact Cistus Creticus.
So that's kind of neat.
And going back to my original point,
it's still Cistus Creticus, or
at least a species of Cistus,
Cistus that grows in
Morocco, believe it or not.
It's still used to make Chanel
No. 5 and things like that.
So I thought that was really interesting.
So I thought it fits,
but you see already here,
in retrospect, I thought
I had to be more careful
because I was in fact also,
it's helpful to have this
previous scholarship,
but also you can see I was leaning
towards something
aromatic and more cosmetic
because they called it
a perfume oil workshop.
So this is gonna be like lesson two
that I'm gonna find later on.
Because what I found
out is the ingredients
don't quite overlap perfectly,
what we would call a perfume today.
But you can even see the original scholar,
Cynthia Shelmerdine in '85.
She translated this
linear be a certain way.
This is an example where interpreting it
can be tricky, right?
This isn't something
canonical like, Euripides,
or you know, Virgil,
or something like that.
These are just tablets that
nobody else are gonna read.
So she translated it with
that perfume angle as well,
because that's what people
were saying a hundred years ago
saying, this is a perfume oil industry.
But you see, and then
later on, Tom Palaima
who is a MacArthur winner
for his work with Linear B,
so he's the best of the best, right?
Translated slightly different.
But what I would argue is that
he is not a chemist, right?
So for instance, he put down unguent,
which means that it's
solid at room temperature.
And based upon the evidence I've gathered
from not just the site in
East Crete but elsewhere,
it's clear almost certainly
that it was never a fat based,
you know, or something like that,
a solid at room temperature.
So even though he might
be the best translator,
Linear B, he's absolutely wrong.
If he understands the technical terms
as they're defined today.
So again, this might sound
like an exercise in hubris,
but it shows you the power
of interdisciplinarity,
where we work together and
we can inform each other.
So without the science backing
me, I would not do this.
But in essence, I'm saying,
well, there's another way
to probably translate it, right?
So I'm trying to veer
us away from perfumes
because as I'll show you in a second,
the ingredients suggest,
the evidence suggests,
you know, for instance,
this isn't a normal vat,
you can see this weird spout in front.
And in fact, it's more
pharmacopeic in nature, right?
And it's certainly not a ongoing,
it's something like an ointment,
the literal translation oil boiler.
And I could say for for
the purpose, it's infusing,
because of the evidence I've gathered
from this archeological context.
I tested, you know, 80 vessels,
there's no sign of burning on this vat.
It's clear that the burning is happening
in a room next door
with these cooking pots.
And here that it's kind
of in this big vat,
they're infusing it.
So anyway, the science again,
is informing the translation.
And I met Tom at a conference, I was like,
"Oh my gosh, he's gonna
say, 'What are you doing?'"
But he said, "No, this
is, keep doing this.
This is incredibly helpful
for people like me,
the science helping the
more humanistic endeavors."
And unless you think
this is a one-off deal.
Another example, again,
it sounds like an exercise in hubris,
but I found evidence for
different storax resins.
And in fact, based upon the
description of the father
of natural history, Pliny the Elder,
writing in the first century,
it's clear that when he
was describing his inferior
and superior storax in Latin,
that he's actually almost
certainly describing
two different species, right?
Things like that, so I actually
went back to the Pliny,
and told my Latinous
friend that he actually,
it's not even that people
are translating wrong
in the modern day, but actually
Pliny is misunderstanding it
because he has different sources.
He's presuming it's from the same plant
and it's just better qualities,
but in fact they're coming
from different plants.
So that's the kind of
information we can give.
Why did I start veering
more towards pharmacology?
Because in this very same
perfumed oil workshop,
there were copious
amounts of ferulic acid.
And at first you can think it comes from,
you know, giant fennel.
But again, that's not really
aromatic of that sort.
And it doesn't really have a property
like coriander to be an astringent.
In fact, it's really
either if you're going
with giant fennel, it's culinary,
and this, it definitely isn't a kitchen.
So then all of a sudden, what
I thought about is the fact
that other species of
ferula, besides giant fennel,
have very pharmacological properties
that are still front and center
in this region of the world.
On top of that, this is where
the transdisciplinary approach
comes in, there's a society
in modern day now Libya,
the entire city state was
founded on this one commodity
they had, called Silphium.
It was so important that they
harvested it to extinction.
So we can talk about ancient ecology now.
The last example supposedly was presented
to the emperor Nero as a curiosity
because it was the last example.
And they had, you know,
leveraged it to extinction.
So this society, their coins were based
upon this ferula plant,
and it was more valuable than gold.
And the fascinating thing about is,
it's one of those instances where Pliny
is usually very verbose
about and specific about
the purpose of these plants
to the point of being speculative.
But what's fascinating is he
doesn't really talk too much
about it, as you can see in this quote.
So you gotta do other research.
And what you find out is when
they're referencing Silphium,
like Avid, another author
says something like,
"If those two keep it up, they're
gonna need some Silphium."
Right, so what we realized
based upon acid found
in the modern day, so and so forth,
and other studies done
in the last centuries,
people have claimed it's in,
I believe it's probably in,
at least in human history
the strongest abortifacient,
right, in quantities enough,
unless you think I'm being speculative,
because Cyrene occurs some centuries later
than the workshop I studied.
In the room next door to
the perfume old workshop,
we found a seal.
And it was, this was excavated,
not in recent memory,
but by the original
excavator, Richard Seager,
in the early 20th century.
And people were like, "What
is this seal doing here?"
Because it's a silphium seed.
So it raised all these questions,
Silphium wasn't really supposed
to be used for, you know,
until centuries later
from this time period.
Silphium's only supposed
to grow in Cyrenaica,
the modern coast of Libya.
So there are all these questions,
but all of a sudden the, so
this makes me more confident
that there might have
been some kind of Silphium
used in this workshop because
of this additional evidence.
And on top of that, I think
it also opens the possibility
that this isn't just simply
an aromatic cosmetic facility.
So then I started to rethink
how to approach this.
So with those lessons I
learned around 20 years ago,
you know, just fast
forwarding over a lot of years
of trying to figure this all out,
that led me here to New Haven
and the Yale Ancient Pharmacology Program.
But you can see the pillars of my research
are based upon that original work
of approaching it from different angles,
relying upon a more
social science approach,
and ethnography, the science
and then the technology,
and also including the
ethnography, of course,
are the humanistic approaches with texts.
And you can see being
based at the Peabody Museum
is a fantastic thing, because
I could walk down the hall,
I could talk to Patrick Sweeney,
reference the wonderful herbarium there.
I could walk down to Mineralogy,
talk about petrography
and all those other kind of things.
And of course, the vast
anthropological division as well
with this millions of objects,
I could start studying these things.
And as you can see in the lower right,
these wonderful students
coming from all kinds of backgrounds,
I mean biochemistry to Classics, to NELC
and everything else in between.
So working with them to try to figure out
some of these mysteries.
How do I go about doing this data
is really the most important thing,
as you can imagine from
all different angles.
And we need robust data,
kind of a two-pronged approach.
Both legacy collections, which
is abundant here at Yale.
Millions of objects just
waiting to be studied.
As we were just talking about earlier on.
There are, I mean untold
amounts of pottery
from Dura-Europos,
never will be displayed.
They're not pretty, but
they're incredibly interesting
to my eyes, because they're still
in their original bags all dirty.
That's what I need to
get the organic sample.
So it's gonna be overlooked
by most art historians,
probably, if not all.
But then there's incredible
data in there for me.
But you also need new field work, right?
Especially things like
ethnobotany, so on and so forth.
So we kind of have that approach,
and we have these collaborations.
So in the title I mentioned cross campus.
One of the nodes of research
is my ethnohistory team.
And we work closely with the
Yale Babylonian collection.
And this is an example of a mystery
that we've somewhat solved.
I mean, this is a vessel
from the days of JP Morgan
inscribed with the great
King of Persia, Xerxes.
And people could have
speculated that, you know,
where they're from,
they're exceedingly rare
and only found the most elite of context.
The tomb of Mausolus, the
namesake of Mausoleums
so on and so forth.
And the Yale Babylonian collection
has an amazing intact
piece that's on display now
or will be soon in the
new exhibit at the museum.
We did these studies and they
contain opiates, all right?
So we can start thinking
what they're doing here.
And we can kind of extrapolate that.
So, and King Tut's tomb, this
was a mystery never solved,
but people don't realize
that King Tut's tomb
was looted twice.
The first time it was looted,
they took barely anything,
we think some medals,
things that are portable
and then they fled.
The second looting incident
was much more systematic.
They left all the portable jewels
and gold and things like that.
In fact, you know, what they took was,
this is the vessel you
see here is maybe like
the volume of a soda can,
something like 330 milliliters,
these vast pharaonic
versions of this vessel,
right at the height of
ancient Egypt power.
There are dozens and dozens
of these calcite jars
that was filled with the
same kind of brown substance.
And that second looting
incident, all but one of these,
two of these jars, they
put them into sacks.
You can see still the finger marks
from these large calcite vessels.
And we know they put them in sacks
because they looted it so
hastily, they left one of them.
And there are remnants of this sack
with this brown stuff in it.
So never studied, and
part of the narrative
of King Tut's tomb that's
never been talked about, right?
The fact that of all the
treasures they could have stolen,
more than the first
slight looting incident,
their main concern was
getting probably opiates.
So fascinating.
We're also working with
the archeology department
because what we do, since
it's about landscapes,
also the ecology, so we
have these wonderful people,
the Yale Center for Earth Observation
is helping us doing
multi-spectral analysis.
And that's, I'll talk
about more in a second.
There's an island off the
coast here owned by the museum.
And it allows us to do all these
kind of interesting studies
that are trying to push the envelope
of the data we could get.
But there's a parallel plan, like I said,
with the field work.
So we're working with the Thebes
Museum, they're wonderful.
George Syrimis in the
lower right is the Director
of the Yale Hellenic Studies Program.
So working with him as well,
because again, there's
this ethnographic component
that he's been incredibly helpful with.
And working with the locals hand in hand.
And then we have for instance,
at the botany angle here
at the Yale Herbarium, as I
mentioned Patrick Sweeney.
I mean there are specimens
from over 150 years ago
collected by the founder of the herbarium.
So wonderful access to things
like here, very early grapes.
And there's, again, there's
a para loan in Greece
where with the locals we're
collecting the very plants
mentioned by these ancient authors
that were supposed to cure
all kinds of different things.
Absolutely fascinating,
so for instance, here,
Helleborus Niger, the
individual there, he said,
"Well, for you guys, this
is one species to you.
But the way we've learned
it, and I believe it is,
we have seven different
valleys where we've categorized
seven different versions of these plants."
I mean, he's not saying it's a subspecies
or anything like that, but
clearly as they understand that,
they call it the local
ecologies are that specific,
the soil, so on and so forth.
So we're starting to investigate
these kind of things.
I mean, there are legends written
by these ancient historians
about these plants.
So we're starting to try to
get to the bottom of this.
And having the medical
historical library here
is absolutely amazing.
They have one of less than
50 facsimiles of what I think
is probably my favorite ancient document.
The Vienna Dioscorides,
the Juliana Anicia Codex,
the original, of course is in Vienna,
and it was written 1,500 years ago for,
you can't make this stuff
up, for a Roman princess
who then got married into
the power of the time,
the Byzantine Empire,
and that royal family.
She brought it to
Constantinople, modern Istanbul,
where sometime, you
know, during her lifetime
or shortly afterwards, she gifted it
to the Imperial Hospital
in Constantinople.
And most important for my research,
then for a thousand years
plus, it was used as a guide
for actual practitioners of medicine,
pharmacy, so on and so forth.
Eventually given to the Sultans,
after the Ottomans took
over Constantinople,
the Sultan's Jewish physician who then,
and then after him, it
got gifted to I think
a Flemish diplomat who gifted
it to the Holy Roman emperor.
That's how it got to Vienna.
But you can see here in
the right, it's remarkable
because that center portion,
so this portion is the
original first century text
of De Materia Medica, right?
Dioscorides, the author himself,
has an incredible story,
which I won't get into here,
but you can see all the different hands.
It's not, so the original
text is Byzantine Greek.
A lot of the Scholia is Greek's
that was used in Constantinople.
But you'll also know there
is a scholia marginalia
in Turkish, Arabic, Hebrew,
a slew of others, Persian.
And in fact, one of my students
who's looking at analysis,
there's actually a Germanic,
or very early Germanic
writing on it, probably done in Vienna.
So it's absolutely astounding.
And there really is no
translations of this scholia.
My students love this because
the closest example is,
again, it's fiction is really
the Harry Potter potions manual.
So if you guys know that story, right?
The value was not really,
if you know the narrative,
it's not in the original text,
but it's with Professor
Severus Snape, right?
As I understand it,
putting all these notes in,
"This is how you cut this plant.
Don't use that plant,
use the side of a knife."
And that's exactly what the
Vienna Dioscorides is all about.
And we're just starting
to plumb those depths
because it falls through the cracks.
Who's gonna study it, is a
botanist that's gonna study it?
Is the Classics that's gonna study it?
Is a NELC scholar gonna study it?
The fact of matter is, and I
can still relate to this book,
it very much falls through the cracks
and we're just starting to explore it.
For instance, as the
herbarium director told me,
it was made for a
princess, it's so accurate.
The illustrations, you
can identify species.
So all of a sudden these,
again, going back to translate,
we don't know what plant
this is in the Linear B text,
all of a sudden we can say, "Well,
at least in this time
period, we know what species,
we can identify the species of plant
and we know what the Greek says.
So at least we can put in that moment.
This was their understanding
of how they identified the plant."
First time ever, but nobody's really,
maybe someone's thought about doing it,
but you can see the difficulties in fact
of actually putting the
expertise together to do it.
When I asked the Medical
Historical Library,
how does this book exist here?
Because there's five
books in the original,
it's exquisite, accurate,
facsimile made in 1970
to the point that you can still
see the body fingerprints,
it's the exact same
size, so on and so forth.
It took separate library
endowments to buy each book.
I can't imagine what the cost was in 1970,
but it surprised me that four
of the books were never opened
and then you still have
the little, you know,
endowed by this family or that
family was never attached.
So I asked the staff there, like,
"Why did you buy this,
and who is this for?"
And then they paused for a second.
They said, "Apparently it
was purchased for you."
And that was a really nice sentiment.
It only took 50 years.
I'm glad they purchased it.
So again, we're connecting
to these oral histories.
We're working with the local people,
and we're working towards
the first purpose-built
lab for ancient pharmacology.
So this is a photo of our
pedator in the basement
of the museum right now.
Great space, but we actually want to make,
we're renovating a 1600
square foot modular lab
in West campus where all this
can happen in one location.
And again, this wouldn't happen
without the wonderful students.
So Ria Singh was a first year student
in the collection of the
Peabody Museum seminar.
And she gamely joined the team
and she's doing this wonderful
work, ethno botanical work
with another mystery we solved.
It's a whole other talk,
but we solved this mystery
of what this installation
in what is now the border of
Egypt and Sudan was all about.
It was a wine installation.
And she's helping me look
at the earlier plants.
I showed you the
specimens of the different
vidas plants in the herbarium.
And we're connecting those dots.
So, as I kind of happily say,
if a student joins my lab,
they're certainly gonna work,
you know, with the
primary research mission.
And then, our last angle, of course,
is the technological angle
because it's a ton of data.
How do you deal with terabytes
and terabytes of information?
And of course, right
in house at the museum
we have the informatics division
led by Nelson Rios and others.
So it's just been a wonderful luxury
to have all these specialists helping us.
Just very quickly, the
way I want to end is
I do want to cite this challenge
that we're facing in case there are
archeologists in the room,
aspiring archeologists.
We're dealing with 150 year plus tradition
of how to do archeology.
So this is from just two looted tombs.
We need to get data, but the same time,
the way it works now, for better or worse
is that you wanna find spectacular
things typically, right?
To get grants, you wanna find
palaces, so on and so forth.
The way that we frame the
project now, the program,
it allows us the luxury
of being more strategic.
Because if you wanna do this right,
this is just from one rescued tomb.
You can imagine how many millions
of shirbs are coming out.
This wasn't even our rescue excavation.
That's from a previous rescue
and they're asking us to study it.
So if you indiscriminately do archeology
as traditionally done,
we're talking about decades of commitment.
And so we've tried to think
about different way to do it.
So one way to do it differently
is, rather than showing up,
you know, all jet lagged in Greece
and just taking days to set up,
we train our students on
Horse Island, as I mentioned,
and they do exactly everything
we would do in Greece,
from the botanical, you know, specimens
to the UAV techniques.
So they were surprised this past summer,
the first time we did this is,
because our students
hit the ground running.
They knew exactly what to do
and it was the best compliment
that the local authorities gave us.
"How are they just on the fly doing this?
There's usually like a training
process, a feeling out process."
And I explained to them
this wonderful resource
that the Peabody Museum has
provided to save us that time.
'Cause many of our students
have internships to go to.
They have senators to intern for,
they wanna go work at the
London School of Economics
or Stern, so we squeeze this
in, in a very tight season,
typically less than a
month in May and June,
before they have to go
off to their internships.
So just very quickly, this
is really another talk
for another time, and I
wanna wrap up here soon,
but these are just the goals
that, for this audience,
for the most part it will
seem pretty innocuous.
But when archeologists typically see this,
I presented this at the
Archeological Institute of America
conference early this month.
And people said on one hand,
"I can't believe you're
doing this, I have to do it."
And on the other hand, they were saying,
"This has been a long time coming
because we need a sustainable model
in terms of doing archeology."
How do we do it in C2?
How do we do it without
having millions of objects
sitting in our collections gathering dust,
not looked at for a century?
So prioritizing this
approach, being very targeted,
looking at microclimates in
collaboration with the locals,
and finally making it sustainable,
which is a very tall order.
So just to sum up now, time
for some glamour shots,
if you'll, you know, amuse me.
So believe it or not,
this is not something
that we kind of front load,
because maybe in a more
traditional dig they would do it.
It's kind of cool, we're
digging Homeric sites, right?
If you guys, most of you probably
of course know the Iliad,
but these are somewhat obscure sites,
but we're confident that we've identified
these two sites correctly.
So it's in this region of
southern focus we're, I'm the PI,
it's near the ancient side of
Delphi, but it's overlooked
because it's overshadowed
by this classical,
very famous classical
sanctuary of the oracle there.
But we want to go before even
Delphi was really even a site.
This was centuries before.
So the Homeric, the Bronze Age period.
And it's cloaked in legend
and all kinds of myths.
I mean Mount Helicon,
the land of the Muses
where I collected that
hellebore, by the way,
which is so cool.
And of course Delphi is nearby,
but also the site that we're
gonna work out work at.
That's where Mark Anthony
mustered his troops and got grain
before he fought at Actium with Cleopatra.
I mean, crazy things have
happened here, the histories.
So this is nearby is where
King Philip and Alexander
subdued the local populace
to become the rulers
of the ancient Greek world and
start the Hellenistic period
all the way to South
Asia, so on and so forth.
So incredible history
that we're working at.
So you can see our site
up, that's Mount Parnassus,
another very famous
mountain in the region,
kind of like the start
of the Balkans there.
We're at that zone, a very sleepy village.
No tour buses come here,
unlike very nearby,
Delphi is just off here to
the side across the valley.
And this is the site most
of you probably know,
many of you have probably
even been to Delphi.
Our side is this mountain
range, so across this valley,
but we're concentrating on this area
because of a couple reasons.
One, it's overlooked, but
this is where a lot of the,
from, I mean it's a cool story,
I won't get into it too much,
but for instance, Hippocrates's
ancestor supposedly
used the hellebore to
subdue a nearby rival town
by contaminating their water source.
And apparently they all
got dysentery and weakened
and they were able to subdue
this neighboring city state.
So the legend goes, his
descendant was so despondent
about this family history, he said,
"I gotta do something about,"
and you guys can probably
guess what that is.
It's the Hippocratic Oath of doing,
I mean this is, I mean it's,
this is like a brief many
layers of history here.
It's absolutely amazing.
So this is the town, there's
a entire Roman city underneath
of Antikyra, but we are not
concentrating down so much.
But the periphery incredible stuff.
This is just picking stuff
off the ground at our site.
It both excites us and scares us,
because if this is coming out the surface,
then we know that there's
tremendous stuff under the ground.
And that requires,
again, time and expertise
that we have to be very careful about
because that might take us
away from our main focus.
As crazy as it sounds,
the authorities are like,
"We've never met people like you
because typically you guys just wanna dig
the mega on and get all the gold.
So you guys are very strange
and very interesting at the same time."
I take that as a compliment.
I mean, we're finding
bronze pins on the surface.
I mean, it's incredible.
So I just wanna do this
quick view of the site,
obviously very beautiful.
You guys are welcome to visit.
I know it's probably not gonna be much,
take much to convince.
It's a Homeric site, it's
fortified, incredible harbor.
But this is Greece, it's just,
I know people look at the greatest hits,
the Athenian Acropolis,
so on on and so forth.
That's one of the locals,
not one of our students.
Our students are down
here collecting pottery,
but people always say
very "Lord of the Rings."
Never excavated, and it's a Homeric site.
We're doing geomorphology.
This was a peninsula at the time,
but there was probably
water all along this area.
There's still a perennial stream here,
which is very unusual for Greece.
So, you know, the water
source was tremendous.
And then just very quickly, the work
that the wonderful students
are doing, this is a 3D model
with such accuracy we can
see shirbs on the ground.
Alright, so again, trying
to do things differently.
And finally, I want to kind of end
by pointing out again the history of this.
There's a very famous second century
Greek Roman, Romanized Greek, Pausanias.
He kind of wrote the first,
I don't know what the
modern equivalent is,
is someone in the audience can tell me,
I used to say blue guide,
but students don't know what
a blue guide is anymore.
So TripAdvisor maybe, he
basically travels the countryside
of Greece in the second century
and explains what all
these sites are all about.
And he mentions, for instance,
in a somewhat obscure text,
he's walking in this
very region and he says,
"By the way, the most important sanctuary
for the Egyptian goddess Isis is here."
Me being me, you could
triangulate exactly where it is.
So I was here a couple years
ago when I started working
and I said, "What is this little
pin I put in Google maps?"
I looked at it, I realized I
put it in over 10 years ago
based upon this text saying,
"If you've ever near
this area, look at this."
And what I realized is that I'm here now.
So I looked, and this
site almost certainly
is this temple complex of Isis,
probably at at least in early stage,
might be a temple to Artemis.
So like the bookend to
the sanctuary of Apollo.
And just on the other side of this valley,
if you guys know legends
just underneath here,
that's where Oedipus killed
his biological father.
I mean you can't again make this stuff up.
It's just steeped in history.
And what's interesting is
the references to this site,
Pausanias goes on and on about it.
It's a mystery, so it can't
go into too many details,
but it's clear people
came here to get healing.
Roman emperors came here to get healed,
never been excavated.
So again, a very interesting site for us
to do our type of research
to try to figure out
what kind of medical approaches
might they have been using
2000 years ago.
So just in the time we have, I
think I have a couple minutes
so you can see how breathtaking it is.
So this is right, never excavated.
And the reason why the grass
is, oh, there's actually audio.
One of my students made it.
There's so much marble here
that the soil is so poor.
That's why there's probably
grass growing there.
That's Parnassus, Delphi
is just down the road here.
(soothing music)
My previous EVST 40 student
in the first year seminar
at the Peabody Museum,
he got a UAV license
and he's the one that did this.
So wonderful students,
a beautiful landscape.
So this is gonna be one of our goals for,
oh by the way, we're flying it from here.
Thank goodness for the Germans
building these power supplies.
They make roads where we could actually do
this kind of surveying work.
And there's the site, almost
certainly the original site,
the upper Acropolis with all the temples,
and beneath it there was
probably a whole complex
of medical treatments,
but nobody traditionally in archeology
is interested in excavating
a medical complex, right?
So I sure am.
So that's kind of where
the future is leading.
And now the question is what
are the future discoveries
both here at Yale but also overseas.
Thank you for your time.
(audience clapping)
- Thank you so much for this
utterly fascinating talk.
I think we are open for Q and A.
Would you be open-
- Off course, yeah.
- for questions from
- I'd happy to.
- The audience, yeah?
- take any questions.
- Yeah.
- I know it's a lot.
There's a lot of information, so.
- [Attendee 1] Thank you
so much for a great talk.
I'm a forest ecologist, so
I work in the modern day,
but I'm very curious on when
you're looking at plant species
that were present in those areas
and looking at medicinal
uses, what evidences you found
for trade routes or changes in climate
and things like that that
have affected both, you know,
locally available plants,
but also plants that
were coming from abroad?
- That's a great point.
What's interesting about
plants such as Black hellebore
is that at least the ancient
authors from this time period,
and again, you gotta always vet them
and see how much they actually knew.
They claim what made this
area of Antikyra special
was these plants, right?
And they only grew here.
I mean, what does it mean only grew?
Is it the specific type
of class of these plants
that they imagined, because
we know Black hellebore
grew elsewhere as well, right?
So that once again is why
after a 10, 20 year journey,
when the opportunity
come to Yale, you know,
arrived at, you know, just
fortuity came up to me,
I was at MIT at the time, which was great.
But obviously in terms of
the humanistic opportunities
there, they're much more limited.
All the humanities and
social sciences are basically
in one building, and on the
other side of the track.
So it made it difficult for
me to collaborate with them.
But these are the exact questions
that we're trying to get to.
So that's why I don't just
invite archeology students
or Classists or NELC students to work.
But the fact that the
School of Environment
is so closely linked to the museum,
the director, Dave Skelly
being a part of the school,
that was highly attractive to me,
because looking at people
doing green chemistry
or the, like, the work that you are doing.
My original GIS mentor, Dana
Tomlin in Philadelphia at Penn,
he's now here at Yale.
And he was inspirational, is inspirational
because in the seventies he
and a whole bunch of his peers,
remarkably, can you imagine the seventies,
they helped basically invent GIS, right?
I mean they ended up, he's the only one
that stayed in higher education,
but the rest went on to
establish Esri, IDRISI
and all kinds of other places.
So I knew that it was possible at Yale,
and that's exactly why
I'm here for that reason,
to start delving into these
very questions of ecology.
I didn't get into it, but this site itself
is actually the sister
site to the coastal site.
And what's neat is we're
starting to take cores
and things like that, because
there was a lake nearby.
So just thinking about
this fourth dimensionally
in terms of time and
everything else like that,
nearby is a very famous
basin, the Kopais Basin,
where in this time period
they drain those swampy,
they drained the entire
land and it's clear
at the collapse of the Bronze age,
probably a neighboring town
stuffed their drain hole.
And it got swampy again.
And to show you of that accomplishment
that was done in let's
say the 14th century BCE,
the Romans, everybody else tried,
just like with the canal at Corinth.
They tried repeated
attempts to complete this
very ambitious engineering work.
It wasn't until first of French helped.
So it wasn't drained again
until the 19th century,
you know, in the modern day.
So there's all these questions,
we're collecting data,
we've taken cores in the sea
to look at the pollen record
and other things like that.
But reason why have I love doing this
with an audience like this is
because then we start
getting ideas and it's,
like I said, it's about collaboration.
So we eventually want, we are doing now,
we're inviting all kinds of scholars.
There's opportunities
as you can imagine for,
as one administrator put it,
there might be somebody from any division,
department in the university
that could go there
and find something to do.
Paleontology, there's fossils
just coming out everywhere.
So it's a remarkable opportunity
and definitely ecology is a major part
of what we're trying to look at.
- [Attendee 2] Yes, thank
you. Fascinating talk.
I wonder if DNA is preserved,
I presume it is preserved,
and if DNA analysis would inform your work
and your findings.
- This again, this is
why I love being here,
because as you might know with,
there was a major study done
with the Max Planck Institute,
the Harvard study of the human past.
David Reich over in the med school.
They've done some ancient DNA studies,
but typically, of course,
with human remains.
And one of the things I
knew, from what I heard,
like for instance when
ESC was founded here,
they had some kind of pioneering DNA lab,
which is now I think
down in the med school.
But certainly when I
started taking soil samples
and other things like that, started to see
where people are with
this type of research.
There are credible besides
just, you know, pollen cores,
you know, looking for
pollen and palaeofaeces
and so on and so forth.
I think certainly that's
a very promising angle.
And of course one of the
reasons why I'm in Greece
is that they are collaborative in ways,
archeology is so important to them.
It's both a pro and a con, right?
Because they are so powerful.
It's arguably the most important
branch of their government
because of the 40% of their
income comes from tourism,
as you might know.
So it could create a
certain kind of bureaucracy,
but at the same time
people don't ask questions
when it comes to the science part.
They absolutely want the
best science to be done.
And an example of that
is in just neighbor,
it's not necessarily good or bad,
but it's the system over in Italy,
you can't really sample or study.
Even if you want a UAV
photogrammetry scan,
an invert paleontology sample,
they won't from I heard.
The Italian government system
is such that you can't do it.
I proposed that in mark
Parnassus, it's like an up zone.
And they actually said to me,
"Why do you want us just scan it?
Why don't you just, we'll chop
it and we'll give it to you
and you can take it to New Haven."
We're like, "Okay, we
probably don't wanna do that."
But that shows you how collaborative
and cooperative they are.
I love working in Egypt.
I love my colleagues there,
but they have a strict rule,
even if it's a toy under 250 grams,
which is the definition of, I think,
in the field in this UAV technology
with how the world recognizes it.
You can't fly single UAV in Egypt.
And our collaborators,
Nadine Moeller at NELC,
and Greg, her co-director there,
they're having a heck of a
time, like, how do you actually
basically not have this major
technology in archeology?
I mean, we're doing thermal imaging,
we're doing multispectral analysis.
Going back to the ecology
of it, it's absolutely,
as I pointed out, the multispectral work
that we're testing out in Horse Island
and we're starting to use in Greece.
We're happily sharing this
technology, and information,
and data with all the faculty
and collaborators in Greece.
And almost exclusively,
this is very interesting.
It's not the archeologists
that want the data,
it's all the scientists that want it.
So that's neat to me
that, I'm very flattered,
and humble that the archeologists that,
I mean, we work with archeologists,
but the scientists are
perhaps the most excited
over in Greece about this, which is neat.
But DNA, yeah, we want to get there too,
because you're absolutely right.
I know what you're thinking
about with the plants
and the Vienna Dioscorides,
but you've read my mind
that that's certainly an
angle we wanna pursue.
- [Attendee 3] So some of the compounds
that modern pharmacologists study.
- Sure.
- Came from
ethno pharmacologists or people who,
even amateurs who just go around the world
trying to sample drugs
that people are taking now.
- That's right.
- [Attendee 3] And I'm just wondering,
in any of the locations
where there's archeologically
interesting chemical use, are
there any remnants of that
among the local populations in terms of,
you know, plants that
people use for various,
usually it's something that
has an effect on the brain.
Those are the things that
people tend to pick up.
- That's the thing, it's like,
one of the things I think
we're doing is that just like,
when you look at the Vienna Dioscorides,
we say book five is about food,
book one, one part of it
is about psychedelics.
These are modern terms.
Like it's clear that they
kind of loosely put them
into these books, but they
didn't mean to categorize it
that distinctly, right?
These are just organics you consume
and it somehow affects your body.
I'm not saying that we
should get rid of categories
in the modern day, but I'm just proposing,
maybe we've gotta kind of think
outside the box a little bit
and think about how all of these things,
like how do our modern
systems and sensibilities
affect the way that we interpret it,
and look at these things.
What I'm trying to get back to,
an example of what you just mentioned
is that in south of our site,
in the Peloponnese there,
in Arcadia, up in the hills,
that's often where the interesting
information comes from.
I still remember this, and
I'm gonna try to go back to it
because I was just passing through there,
and I was kind of doing, you
know, this kind of research.
I didn't have a program,
again, a square peg,
trying to figure out which
department I was gonna be in.
And we met a local and said, "Oh,
my family for centuries was doing
what you would call maybe pharmacology."
So she said, "Do you wanna see it?"
So I went to their shop and you know,
there's newspaper on the frosty glass,
it's probably hadn't been
used for a generation.
She lets me in, it took my
breath away because it has,
it's probably maybe something
more along the lines
of what we'll call like an apothecary.
So the beautiful wooden
shelve and everything else,
like the beautiful glass jars.
And now it kind of, I gotta get back there
and I'm not sure, I mean,
I'm not holding out hope,
it's anything still there,
but all the glass jars were
labeled in the beautiful,
more modern Greek script.
And then they specifically
labeled not just
how they viewed it as a substance,
but also there was their
details about what plants,
where they collected it from.
And I'll give you a, I
don't usually like to
kind of be a downer, but
let me just share you
where is that, hope I can find that.
So I knew, there is a sense of urgency.
Like I don't like to necessarily
push people to scare them,
but I'll give you an example.
So these three individuals,
they lived up in that mountain village,
and we did an interview with them.
And they're telling us
all this information,
"Oh, you're looking for this."
They loved us, they're like,
"Nobody in the younger
generations really at all
interested in this kind of research."
So we videotaped it with their consent,
we wrote it all down,
this is just a start.
We're gonna get all
this great information.
2018, that winter, all
three of them passed away.
That's what's going on.
And we thought all was kind of lost.
And what ended up happening was,
I showed you that earlier
picture with the gentleman.
We had the sample of Black hellebore.
And by some miracle we found him,
he's actually the grandson of
the individual in the middle.
And he said, he's in the sixties,
and he said, "Look, I'm the
last, at least in this area.
I think I'm gonna be alive
for a number more of winters,
but if you're gonna do this
and get information from
me, it's the time now.
I'm not sure if I'm gonna live."
You know, he's like 68 or
something like that, right?
And he said there's a sense of urgency.
So that's why I realized I need this team
of research assistants.
We're gonna go there this
summer, for instance,
and we're gonna go to every single valley
he points out and document
in every fashion if possible.
And you can imagine we have
support at the highest levels
from the Greek ministries,
because they understandably know
that we're passionate about this,
but also working with the locals.
They, again, this is not something
that you gotta be worried about,
but there's a certain relationship
between foreign institutions
of archeology, you know,
foreign institutions
like the American school
has been working there
since the 19th century.
There's a certain, let's just say
there's a certain
relationship that's developed
in the 150 years, and that's
kind of the status quo.
So what, when we come in and
we work in the way we do,
as I pointed out, the
locals are absolutely,
one, flabbergasted, but
obviously they're very supportive
of what we do because we work
hand in hand with the locals.
I don't think I'm being that
quote unquote disruptive.
I'm just doing it the way
I think it should be done.
So, yep.
That's a great question.
We're trying. (laughs)
- [Attendee 4] I just wonder,
I was very curious because,
there are these traditions,
current practice traditions like Ayurveda,
which is really based on
plant science and you know,
there are treatises on which
similarly I wonder, right?
I mean, I have heard in India
there is a scheme of medicine
called Unani medicine,
which is Greek.
- Yeah, yeah.
- [Attendee 4] Yeah, so I was
curious whether these modern
alternative practices
actually also contain
some of the information
that you're looking for,
or do you think these are
actually too contaminated
by now over time?
- The way I explained
it is I view all data
as valuable data, and
you're absolutely correct.
Like, people ask me,
"Why did you major in biophysics
and Classics and NELC?"
And this probably wouldn't
surprise many of you,
bluntly, my parents would've killed me
if I majored in Classics,
as I was pre-med.
So it was kind of a,
it was detente, right?
So it thrilled me when my
student Ria, who you met,
doing ethnobotany, she's from
South Asia and she was just,
you know, FaceTiming with her parents,
and they were like, "Oh, you're
working in the lab you got.
Is your professor there,
or your director?"
And she said, "Yeah."
So I talked to them and
they were so thankful,
because I mean, just to
be again very honest,
my parents would be like, "Ethnobotany?"
Like, "What are you doing here?"
But her parents were
like so thankful, saying,
and they're explaining to
me all these traditions.
And I said, "We're absolutely
gonna pursue that."
And that's why we need people
from all over the world
who are international,
because we're gonna pursue those things.
It's a wealth of information because-
- [Attendee 4] Are they surviving
such traditions in Greece?
I mean, is there-
- They're often-
- (talking indistinctly)
- There often is, but it's missed, right?
Like, I mean if they're not,
if people aren't catching,
and I'm not saying that
they can do everything,
but it's just where
people are focusing now
and these traditions
have been established.
Like the classics, no one reads
really the Vienna Dioscorides, you know,
De materia medica, so on and so forth.
Another quick example,
which is remarkable, is
the last generation who spoke
the native Mayan language,
they also of course
knew the Mayan language,
but they also knew, they
learned Spanish and Latin.
So this is the first
interface between the worlds,
and there's this wonderful beautiful book.
It surprised me even more in a sense
than the Vienna Dioscorides,
because I had no idea this book existed.
It was lost for centuries, right?
It was written the, it's similar
to the Vienna Dioscorides,
it talk about all the
plants in the Americas
and so on and so forth.
Then it was sent, eventually
landed in the Vatican Library
where it was forgotten for
centuries until the 1930s.
The Pope gifted it to Mexico,
and there was one translation done then,
and then it was forgotten again.
So that's a parallel example
where we're looking at these traditions,
and then we're talking to the locals.
And what's also remarkable is that,
for our herbarium is very
strong in the Americas,
and all of a sudden it's like a bridge.
But we're gonna collect more specimens
with the collaboration to
Greeks to add to our herbarium.
But it's another base of operations
'cause there's lots of parallels.
So it sounds ambitious and we
are very sensitive to that.
We wanna make sure what
we do is achievable
as much as possible, but again,
this is why we love talking to different,
you know, different units,
whether it's people that
focus on South Asia,
or Central America, so on and so forth.
That's a great point though.
- [Attendee 5] I recall
that there was a substantial
medical establishment
in what is now called
Pergamon in Turkey.
And I wondered whether that
being substantially later
than bronze age place,
but I wondered whether there
was any information there,
and if there is more
interest in your approach,
whether the Turkish government
is in any way helpful.
- That's a great point
because, of course Pergamon
was where Galen operated from,
who was a very famous physician
whose treatises were used
until fairly modern days.
So next to the Archegesion
where we're working
is Asklepeion of course.
And that's exactly of course
the context in Pergamon
that Galen was operating in.
Again, one of these leading edge
medical facilities at the time.
Of course the library was considered
only second to the library
at Alexandria, of course.
What we think is clearly Dioscorides
had access to the library at Alexandria,
and maybe at Pergamon,
because he comes from what's
today like Southeast Turkey.
And it just so happens in September,
I was at the modern, what's
called in the modern day
Kültepe-Kanesh, which is
a very famous site there,
Gojko Barjamovic who is an
Assyriologist at Harvard,
and married to our curator here,
was kind enough to take me around
after this event in Eleusis in Greece.
Remarkable, and what, again,
broke my heart in a good way
was we're sitting there at Kültepe
and the director Fikri says,
"Oh, you're interested
in this kind of stuff.
You know, like right over that hill
is where Dioscorides grew up and lived."
And he's like, "Do you
wanna go there now?"
And we're like, look like
we're gonna get to the airport
and just like, so one day.
But he said, "Oh, if you want."
Again, working with locals is so important
'cause he said that, I know
Turkey has some different rules
and they're trying to, they
were at our acer meeting
going around saying,
"We know that the rules
have been kind of draconian of late."
The consulate showed up and said,
"Please, we've loosened these rules,
come and work in Turkey."
Coming up to each of us.
They were reading our abstracts.
They came to me and said,
"You're interested in pharmacology."
Where I'm like, "Yes."
And they said, "Please come."
So we're working with them.
And Fikri said, "Look, next time you come,
all those plants that
Dioscorides talks about,
we'll get them for you."
And I thought, "Oh my gosh."
I mean within kilometers
of where he's writing
about these kind of things, right?
So you can imagine, and then of course,
Istanbul, Constantinople,
which is where this
volume was used, right?
And written, I'm very thankful
for the different units here,
because I'm not an expert in
the Turkish language for instance.
But I could go to my colleagues and NELC,
and you know, find somebody
that knows something
about something and it
kind of really supports,
and makes me feel good
about making the move
from Cambridge to New
Haven for that reason.
- I wanna take this up and
just to thank you once more.
And I think it's remarkable that a lot
of big pharma companies
are also in the search
for new natural compounds that we can get,
and they're scouring the world
for indigenous knowledge.
So thank you so much for what you do,
and it was really exciting
for us to hear about it.
So let me just remind everyone.
(audience clapping)
(soothing music)